[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan and i were just
talking about
how i choose to sing songs that are way
out of my range but for some reason i
just like singing them
it's like that uh if you leave me now by
peter cetera
you know what i'm talking about i
probably do but you're too young don't
recognize it all right ryan
that's the singing how's your week bud
fine how was your week
well uh i wasn't gonna bring it up but i
figure you know uh
don't then well you know
i i i woke up this morning and i said
and you need to talk about it i'm like
well
i talk about everything i'm open and and
maybe it's a good idea because it might
help someone and i'm not worried i want
to preface it with don't worry
about me everything's fine
good but i had a mole removed about two
weeks ago
and what i do is i don't really worry
about things after
you know i i just didn't really think
about it i you know you
they say you know if we don't call you
it's fine
so yesterday uh you know jess is in the
backyard with me
and uh i'm on my phone and i listen to a
message from the dermatology center and
they're like
hey michael uh could you please give us
a call when you have a chance
and i was like oh boy well
so i called and sh long story
short
they told me i had skin cancer what yeah
i know i didn't tell you this before so
i'm telling you on the air it's kind of
freaking out but don't freak out because
it's a
um it's weird when someone says cancer
to you whatever it is you know i have
people i know with cancer my good friend
preston who's been battling cancer and i
consider that
real cancer i'm like that's that's
cancer that's
you know you know he's he's been going
through chemo he's been dealing with and
i'm like you know skin cancer that's
but then i've heard so many stories and
you see people and
a girl i know her dad's you know pretty
much dying from that
like so i guess it's like they told me
not to worry
they said you know this is a more of a
common one
uh you know not a lot of risk
and that's why i'm sort of bringing it
up not to say i wouldn't bring it up
before but
i think that you know why i'm bringing
it up is
just i'm like if anybody out there has
something they're looking at
mine was on my thigh and they're like
it's fine
if you just go get it checked out and
looked at and it's and you get catch it
early
you're probably going to be fine like 99
of the time you know people joke
sometimes well skin cancer is the cancer
you want
i'm like well i don't want any cancer i
guess what it is
it's just like just being aware i looked
at my thigh one day and i go
huh it's like irritation or is that what
is that ah
a week later it's twice the size and
then a week later i'm like
eh it didn't look right i don't think
it's a big deal and i asked my friend
carrie i said carrie
actually i don't need to get this
checked out right she goes i would
i would just get it checked out it grew
that fast just
what the hell still i went in there and
my doctor's really chill you know dr
rifkin
uh you know we should just get rid of it
and just i won't cut it out it'd be
nothing it's probably nothing okay cool
and then they call and they're like you
know so they're gonna cut it out deeper
they'll put some sutures in me sutures
yeah and you know they'll check the rest
of my body and
and that's it so all i'm saying is i'm
not worried
they're not worried if they were worried
i'd be a little worried i'd be like oh
crap
you know but they they didn't say the
big m word you know like god god forbid
melanoma or something like horrible but
yeah again if you're like looking at
your body and things are changing you do
so you're not doing anything about it
you're
you're not that's not a good thing yeah
well you're calm about it so i'm
i'm not worried either yeah i am i
really am i um
i felt like there was a calmness that
when came over me yesterday
when they said it it was just this weird
sort of
like obviously people have all these
different things and they're dying all
over the world from different diseases
and things so
first of all when they said skin cancer
i'm like you know you know like
it's fine but i i honestly it puts
things in perspective it kind of makes
you think about your own mortality and
it usually takes that why does it take
that why does it take someone calling
and saying
you have this or we just got to get
ready to make you go oh
so uh you know
again i i'm i really am mentioning it uh
because hopefully my listeners are out
there and anybody who's listening
um just here for jensen access hopefully
you'll like jensen echols enough that
you'll stick around because you like the
podcast but
if they're listening they'll go you know
what i'm gonna go to the dermatologist
so somebody might catch something early
so maybe me saying something might
you know get someone to go in there
because look you think you're
indestructible
i mean even though i've had seven spine
surgeries i'm still like
ah i gotta get cancer my heart's good my
lungs are good my liver is good this is
good i'm not getting that i don't really
go out in the sun a ton
and i don't even know if it's from the
sun yeah i'm going golfing today i don't
give a you know i'm like
it's on my upper thigh it's apparently
not from my son unless i'm uh
golfing in speedos i mean who wouldn't
i know but uh anyway that's it so i hope
you guys go out and get things checked
out you know i hear horror stories all
over the place but
really truly i'm not worried there's no
reason i know a lot of you are very
sweet and
you don't need to say are you okay i'm
thinking about you there's this is fine
it's fine until it's not it's fine
everything honestly
if i was concerned man i'd be like holy
[ __ ]
but it's it's absolutely fun and this is
just really for people out there i
looked at your face and wait a minute i
didn't tell ryan no he did not
until in the air he was what
yeah it's a little weird all right what
else we got here we got a great guest
coming up he's been on the show before
but he hasn't been on
film so we're filming him it is uh
the very i think they're filming as we
speak the final
episode of supernatural of 15 years
um make sure you tune in next week
because uh jared padalecki
is uh they're the two leads jensen
ackles jared padalecki
i'll probably try to get misha again to
come on and uh whoever else but
huge show 15 years and there's a lot of
revelations uh here in these episodes i
think you're gonna
really enjoy it i did i got something
from it and uh
there's a couple of cool little secrets
that uh jensen dave vulgers and then
jared and
uh i think if there were secrets maybe
maybe not maybe i mean
the super fans probably know more what
they obviously know way more than i do
but i've known jensen and jared for a
while and they're just uh
great guys so it was cool it was cool
talking to him
i want to say uh hello to my patrons
uh if you don't know what patreon
patreon is it's uh it's amazing there
it's just extra support for the show
there's all different tiers there's
things where you could ask me questions
on a segment called inside of
me there's uh what else is there ryan
[ __ ] talking you get to ask questions to
the guests
if you're at a certain tier i do private
youtube lives with
my patrons where we play music it's like
a request line
there's um merch packages zooms there's
just
well there's just a bunch of stuff and
then uh so
if you're interested to do it but i just
want to shout out to my patrons who
support the show and uh i love them all
give them a shout out at the end of the
show
and uh yeah also uh if you want band
shirts rose and bomb and dancing go to
rosenbaumandanson.com they're cool band
shirts
um the other t-shirts there just go on
there and
you'll see the shirts and then there's
the inside you online store if you want
to get any mugs or autographed mugs or
shirts or beach towels
well we were also trying this morning
moving [ __ ] around trying to fix this
room and make it open
i hope you like the new feng shui i mean
we're just trying to like this
microphone i feel like i'm leaning to
the left all the time i got
i got to figure something out but i
don't want you to want to see a big mic
in the middle i gotta
maybe it's time for a new mic what's
wrong with these mice
i don't know we'll get into it after
that these are great you like these mics
yeah these are nice but there's ones
that go right into the table
i mean the stands yeah oh well yeah we
can keep the mics and get different
stands
maybe anyway uh thanks for supporting
the show and uh follow us at inside of
your podcast on
uh instagram inside of you pod on
twitter
email your friends thanks for the
support please subscribe please give it
to your uh tell everybody it really
helps if you really enjoy it
uh help us out you know what i mean if
you're enjoying the show then
why not just give a shout out to some of
your friends and force them to uh
right yeah yeah also a big shout out to
westwood one uh
they are our mothership
you know uh so excited to be a part of
westwood one and so many great people my
good friend kelly
and teresa and agnes and uh
and lou there's just so many great
people over there cat just helping the
show
working hard meetings and i i've never
experienced this you gotta understand
guys i've been
doing this podcast and it's me going
ryan what do you think of that
there's like no sales and there's no
people there's all these departments and
it's
it's overwhelming in a really good way
so thanks swiss would one for believing
in us
and everybody more importantly everyone
out there listening who's believed in
us who have believed in us and uh keep
believing
and if you're here again for jensen and
a certain guest
you know subscribe give it a chance i
think you'll learn something i hope you
do i learn something every day
all right let's get inside of jensen
ackles it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience dude you look good man thanks
bloody you too
is that because you're you're
quarantined now right so i am uh i'm
officially back up in vancouver to
finish the last two episodes of
supernatural
which is crazy 15 years and we had two
left
and and uh you know
buyers hit so they pulled the plug and
said we'll let you know
uh and so they've just let us back up i
think we're the first warner brothers
show back on its feet
um from the from the from the big paws
so uh but in order to do so so we fly to
vancouver which is where we film
uh and the canadian government has the
quarantine act in place so you have to
for any traveler flying up
you have to mandatory quarantine for 14
days
and that means like literally not
leaving the threshold of your house
like you cannot go outside for anything
uh so i'm here
figuring out how to use instacart and
figuring out how to use
how to use uh skip the dishes and uh
every other delivery service that i've
never really needed to use before
all right so this is crazy so you do
supernatural for 14
and three fourths or more years this is
the 15th season right
and then all of a sudden you're hey two
episodes left we're ready we got
momentum we're all tired but we're
emotional
let's finish these two boom go back to
texas
jensen and you're there for five months
yes
is it hard to be are you i mean look
you've been doing this so long
do you even get nervous in terms of like
hey it's been five months i've got to
come back and shoot the
two most important episodes of the of
the series and i have a lot riding on it
or you don't take it like that i mean
i've got a lot of mixed emotions about
it uh
you know and rightfully so um you know
moving into
uh the final the final two episodes it
was
we only did 20 episodes a season i'd
like to say the season night
episode 19 was kind of the season finale
and then episode 20 was the series
finale
and uh but as you know
doing a 20 episode or 22 episode or a 23
episode
season like we've been doing for so many
years you get to those last couple
episodes and you're
you're tucker i mean you are spent
uh it's a marathon and so usually what
happens is they
you know you work your ass off for for
nine months and then the last few
the last couple episodes uh are the
biggest
most emotional most you know uh
action-packed
uh crescendo of the entire season so
it's like running a marathon and then
they expect you to sprint the last few
miles
and so it's always it's always pretty
exhausting and
i do remember having the thought of like
uh
i wish we could like regroup and and
you know like have a little have a
little break
and get some you know get refreshed
before going to these and i did not
anticipate a four and a half month
refreshment go get good i'm repressed
i'm ready to go
go get yourself a facial relax for a
couple months do some stretching
i was you know in the beginning i kind
of looked at it at that i was like you
know
let's try to find the positive uh the
silver lining here and it's that
we took a pause before uh the last two
episodes and
and hopefully we can get this pandemic
under control and we can get back to
work and we'll all be
fresh and bright-eyed bushy-tailed we
can knock out uh
season 15 in the the whole series
um it lasted a lot longer than
anticipated now it's like
gonna be so different you know uh yeah
they had to rewrite
a bit of the last two episodes because
of the quarantine and because of the
pandemic and all that stuff
there's some things that we can't do
right we were going to do like you and
jared can't make out
well no no no no that's i mean that was
yeah we're hanging our hat on that yeah
that's
but there are some things that you can't
do there's like some things that are
your
that are you do you have to distance
when you're on set
so well yeah i mean just the the
protocol now
uh as i understand it is you know that
and this is another reason why it took
so long to get us back up here and
working
uh all the unions had to sign off on it
you know you had to get the dta and you
had to get that
the sag and you had to get uh you know
the
transpo and you had to get grips and
electrics and like everybody had to
basically come together come to the
table
and sign off on on these safety
protocols um
and i believe the way it's gonna look is
that
you know all of these different uh
uh crew are gonna have there's gonna be
like little pods so you're gonna have
like grips and electrics in one you're
gonna have
you know camera and sound and another
you're gonna have actors hair hair
makeup wardrobe and another and they're
not allowed to co-mingle yeah they have
to stay
separate which as you know is going to
be a very difficult
thing because yeah i can tell you how
many times i'm sitting there
on set rehearsing and i've got a grip or
an electric you know
over my head tweaking a light which is
or someone's putting you fixing your mic
or someone's fixing it yes
absolutely i mean people are all like
it's a very
tightly interacting group of technicians
and so that's going to add
uh god knows how much time to production
uh they're also adding i think an
additional 60 minutes to lunch
so it's hour and a half now 90 minute
lunches
social distance in the line what about
the days doesn't that make the days
longer
well that makes the days longer but
here's what they did they i guess
maybe they figured out that working past
uh uh
11 hours your immune system starts to
deplete
so now they want 10 hour camera days
hang on that's good
silver lighting silver lining for yeah
for
for you know everybody who doesn't want
to let who doesn't like to work 14 hours
who does but nobody does nobody does
i love they've just figured out that oh
maybe there's a compromise in the immune
system after 10 hours of being on your
feet and
locked in a locked at a sound stage with
atmospheric smoke
um well that stick you think that will
stick even after post all this stuff or
we'll come back to like hey we're back
to 14 days here
i i think i think the 14-day uh
you know huge will be will rear its ugly
head
eventually why are we the only country
that does that it's like think about it
like i just heard i just interviewed
bruce campbell who i
freaking love okay yeah the best come on
and bruce is like he's you know doing
his
his new zealand acts he's like nah mike
we don't get it he's like he was when
he's directing
he's like you know he's like can i get a
i just need an extra hour and they're
like hey let us talk about it
and they get in the corner and they're
like yeah we're not going to give it to
them right
no no no we don't want to go home right
to up to a night so yeah
yeah sorry bruce uh but i mean
i think they gave him an hour because he
was directing his first time directing
and then the rest of the episode they're
like no but they say hey we want to be
done
at seven we want to go home to our
families
that's the way it is and i hear like a
lot of places do that
but uh no not here well i mean you know
you've heard of french hours
so i guess it's a popular thing no lunch
right no lunch
they don't do lunch they just shoot nine
hours then you know i'm sure they bring
out a cart
of cheese and crackers and wine and
stuff at uh every three hours
that's exactly what the french do
yes we got the cheese that's hilarious
you know what though
yeah uh what was i gonna say about that
think about it
how often during the day do you go well
i'm gonna sit at the table for an
hour and have some lunch no you grab a
sandwich you go in the back you sit down
you have a sandwich you look at your
phone you maybe take a nap
people have time throughout the day
jerry might not be working in a scene
you might be working everybody you lunch
is always there
so it's smart [ __ ] lunch let's work well
and that's
i would say i would argue that most
people
have breaks kind of built in due to
their whatever their particular job is
right
show there are a few people that really
don't get breaks you think about
uh you know uh
camera for instance like when they're
shooting
they're obviously very very very
intensely working
but when they're not shooting they're
setting up the shot so they're
so you know i would say camera doesn't
have a whole lot of time
obviously the dp dp's got to be there
setting everything up and then when
we're shooting he's got to be there
making sure he or she's got to be making
sure that the shot is
is still lit properly so i'd say there's
a few
a few people that do need built-in
brakes
but for the most part you're right it's
like
you've got 10 15 20 minutes
every couple hours to go and have a
quick bite or have a
and by the way we do not starve on this
set i mean there's
there are there's constantly food at
craft service
and then on top of that we got catering
making us
breakfast you got catering making making
lunch and then between that
you got craft service building in uh
sandwiches soups and sandwiches
after three hours after call and you got
three hours after lunch you got hot
snack
what's your go-to like they know you
you've been doing this show for 15 years
so look you you guys are the leads
you know there's certain things that
you're like hey they know this is what
jared wants at two o'clock we're gonna
get him this it's not that it's high
maintenance it's just like
you're a lead actor you're working
constantly it's like there's a certain
system it's like a structure a routine
that you know you're good they're good
they know what it so what is it like
when you get to set do they have a
protein shake for you
maybe some egg yolks like rocky had what
is it yeah uh
so jared usually always has this uh
breakfast burrito
uh that's the size of a football and i
believe it it's a massive gut bomb
and it was funny and he'll he'll argue
this with me till we're blue in the face
but he's like
i don't eat breakfast and i'm like you
have a
massive breakfast burrito you know the
size of the size of your leg
every morning he's like yeah but i don't
get up and eat i eat that you know when
i get to work
because breakfast is right when you wake
up i guess and i'm like technically
breakfast is the first time you're
eating since you woke up that's you're
breaking your fast
but what but what about you what do you
get so i usually
will stop uh at uh
at my coffee shop on along the way to
work and i'll pick up like a coffee
and a little breakfast sandwich like a
little you know
egg and cheese sandwich and i'll eat
that and so when i get to work i'm not
tempted to go over to catering and order
a giant
football-sized burrito yeah good call
you know
yeah so i usually don't partake in
breakfast
uh at the studio in the morning
sometimes they'll make me like a little
you know
a little breakfast scramble or something
like that if i'm if i if i'm
if i'm still hungry but but most
i'll wait and i'll get a good lunch i'll
have
they'll make me like a platter with like
you know fruits and vegetables and some
some deli slices and some cheese and
some hummus or whatever they you know
they mix it up for me what's
a no-no though what so what do you know
that if you eat it you're gonna be tired
it's gonna put you in a crash
what do you stay away from throughout
the day so you have the energy
what do you what are you eating what do
you don't eat not eat i try to stay away
from like
the donuts the heavy sugary stuff that
because i don't feel good for you know
five minutes and then you're gonna be
like
i'm gonna be in my trailer sleeping for
the next hour right what about steak
steak's not good during the day isn't it
hard to
i mean if they digest during the uh uh
you know at lunch if they're making
steaks and stuff
i'll i'll have them cut me a little a
few bites
but i'm not i'm not eating big meals
throughout i'm eating kind of like
you know low portions consistently
throughout the day
every hour so carrots fruits
little deli snacks yeah a little little
granola you know
just kind of just just keeping myself uh
sustained
uh so that i'm not you know i'm not
overeating or i'm not
you know crashing have you ever had any
kind of issue where you're like uh
somebody ever came up to you because you
know women have had this for a very long
time and i'm sure guys have had it too
but
where the producer comes up and goes hey
jen so we noticed that you've either
lost a little weight or you've
gained too much weight have you ever had
that i haven't i've had
you know my my makeup artist or
or wardrobe uh gal mentioned something
like you know you're looking a little
skinny or
or whatever it'll be like yeah yeah just
trying to lose a little around the
middle
but it's never been it's never been to a
point right away
then yeah they've never had to call it
closing down go back to texas for
another five months
jensen yeah if anything i think i think
jared's probably fluctuated a little bit
more than i have throughout the years
he's
you know uh depending on what
supplements he's taking
i don't know do you think there was a
in the beginning when you first started
because i'm sure you went through i mean
when you're with each other for 15 years
you're not only you're family i mean you
really become family and friends but
like with that i mean i i know like i've
lost my [ __ ] on welling before on
smallville i've lost my [ __ ] with people
because i hang out with them more than i
have my own family so
was there ever a time where you're like
those moments where
i like this guy i like this guy i don't
like this guy i really don't want to see
this guy for the next few weeks
and i like this guy again all right he's
better now did you guys go in an up and
down thing or is it just kind of like i
love him and
he doesn't annoy the [ __ ] out of me or
he you annoy the [ __ ] out of him i would
say
i mean certainly over 15 years there is
the
uh i don't need to see him right now
sure i'm not knocking on his door the
first thing in the morning
uh i know i'm going to see him in 10
minutes anyway
right i'm sure he feels the same way
sleep i missed you
you know uh but i will say for
the the massive majority of our time
we are buddies hanging out and it's it
you know we have i i think i think it's
been one of the greatest successes of
the show
is is how uh how well and how
consistently we've gotten along both on
and off set
and misha are you tighter with one of
them are they just both equally kind of
your guys no he kind of rounds he kind
of it's interesting he
he adds this perfect like extra extra
trifecta layer you know and and it's
uh i think we all get along and all have
you know i've got
i've got my friendship with misha
jared's got his friendship with misha
and jared and i have our friendship
and but then also we have this kind of
triangular
uh uh relationship as well that just
works it
it works on a public forum and it works
in a private form
who's got the shortest fuse on set if
someone's gonna snap
who's gonna be oh jerry do you guys
enjoy watching this like do you look at
each other like no there he goes
i have literally fire started and lit
his fuse so many times just to sit back
and go
what is it you do is it things like
because a welling would
would have he would do that to me and he
would also
be in a you know i know well i could do
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
he would sometimes he'd be in a pissy
mood and for some reason if i came in
and i was a pissy mood
it'd make him happy he would suddenly
get out of the bad mood he'd love seeing
me lose it
what are we doing why are we filming
they told me to come and sit down and
rush to set him late
and then well he'll turn around while
he's got his hand up to his face he's
like
[ __ ] like you know but i would say um
generally jared and i's uh frustrations
are very much in line
so if something is not working or
something is just seems off or it's it's
it's frustrating i i will
either quickly bring it to his attention
or he'll quickly bring it to mind
and then uh depending on the
the severity of it i also know where
this could go
either he's gonna get wound up and
head you're gonna roll uh or
i'm gonna defuse the situation and and
cooler heads will prevail and
and we'll you know we'll move past it
um very rarely do i get tuned up and
have to
or do i get wound up and have to tune
somebody what's an incident where
jared would have probably been like wow
jensen's going off like jensen never
he's even killed he never loses it
what's the one moment
i could see it you remember it no well
i'm trying to think there's there's been
a few over the years where
where he so he surprisingly uh just got
to sit back and watch me go
although you know he's he is the type
and he's the
good the good friend that he is you know
he he
he's right there behind me to throw in
the insults as well so
uh uh there there have been a few we
we've had some some guard changes in
certain positions over the years and
those people in in their authoritative
position would maybe treat people that
we have a very close relationship with
uh that are underneath their position
and we would start hearing that they
were getting treated less than they
should
and so we would then have to you know
put on our our producer hats that we
actually don't own and
uh and go and go and go set some people
straight
on the kind of behavior that is expected
on this set and
what's that noise what's that noise let
me get rid of it yeah it's
[ __ ] killing me usually i don't hear
anything so i didn't know how i had it
there's my uh dishwasher telling me that
the
dishes are dry okay well tell her
did you tell you once yeah tell me once
i don't need to know what it would have
been perfect timing
that's enough dishwasher so you so
so so someone
is not getting treated as fairly because
someone of a
higher uh important uh whatever the hell
you don't know you know what i'm saying
they're just getting that so you guys
step in and sort of and you probably
hate that you're like [ __ ] now we have
to
because it takes a lot of energy and you
have to deal with something you don't
want to deal with it now you got to deal
with it
yeah well i think you know jared and i
have worked very hard we know that uh
that um you know tone on set is a very
important thing
and you know you've been around you've
you've been on enough sets to know that
that
toxic sets are just exhausting to be on
you know it's it's not fun the work's
not
fun uh you know everybody's walking on
eggshells
and you know the egos are flying off the
hand it's like i
like i don't i don't want to be a part
of i don't want to work in that place
toxic yeah you don't want that
you know so we know that that we have a
heavy hand in setting the tone on this
set
and he and i try to really uh
do justice to that and everybody
should be treated fairly uh best idea
wins no matter if it comes from the
producer director
or a pa who's you know sweeping up the
broken glass
uh i've had my onset carpenter lead into
my ear and be like you know it'd be
funny
and i'm like i'm doing that so
there's a there's a very communal kind
of
feeling that we have on our set and if
somebody has is having a bad day or if
somebody tries to wreck that tone
and and and be a a [ __ ]
then we're usually the ones that call
them out
and handle the situation right do you
think
after five months off in your head
you're sort of like
three months and you're like you know
danielle
your wife you know this um
do you ever go i could do another season
i mean
oh oh yeah all these months off i'm
gonna call the producers and let's go
let's get another one going
that was the longest that's the longest
uh break
break that i've had in 14 years from the
show that's what i'm saying
by the way longer than the writer's
strike in season three
wow that's which was what oh eight i
remember that
yeah yeah oh it was a weight yeah yeah
that's
you know it's also the longest i've ever
gone without traveling anywhere it's the
longest i've ever spent
as long as i've ever spent consecutively
with
your family with my family consecutively
um oh so yeah i mean i'm certainly you
know
certainly ready to go and refreshed and
and you know
ready to get back to work but uh you
know the ship has already sailed on this
being the last season you know jared's
already got another show lined up
uh i've got a few stokers in the fire
so um you know we're uh we're going to
knock this out try to do it justice
i you know i've always
i've always thought that there is a
possibility of you know five years down
the road getting the call and saying hey
let's do a
a little short order action for for a
streaming network and
bring them back for six episodes that's
gonna happen the show's too famous not
to happen
right i mean they'd be silly i mean it's
not like you guys are gonna age that
much in five years i mean i it's been
ten years since i did smallville but
you know i'm a little older but i you
know lex luthor could be able to
still do it i can still do it i'm older
like i'll shave or you know whatever
but yeah you guys could do that so it's
always there it's
timeless it's something that you guys
could do
25 years from now hey what's going on
yeah can you believe we're still doing
this [ __ ] yep we are
and i do feel like this is this isn't
like the long goodbye right now
you know this is i feel like this is a
um you know let's let's put this
let's hang this in the closet for now
and and we'll we'll dust her off you
know down the road a bit
inside of you is brought to you by
better help online counseling
uh this is something that's really easy
for me to talk about i talk about it on
the podcast
and uh that's why they're still around
they're still a sponsor and they um
they just offer such a great service and
uh i think that's
um obvious if you think you might be
depressed
you know obviously these times are hard
and you know
a lot of times not just with what's
going on in the world now but you know
people face a lot of difficulties it's
called life
uh but if you're feeling anxious
stressed or overwhelmed
and uh you know it's hard to talk to
just a friend or someone else and people
have this feeling that they can't talk
to
counselors or there's some but i think
that things are changing
ryan i think that um we're starting to
normalize things especially like
my podcast and and i think people are
starting to be a little more comfortable
and open up and i think
when you open up you uh you become a
better person and i think you're
you get to be more more comfortable with
yourself and understand the things that
go wrong and the things that happen
we're all human we all have flaws and um
it's important it's important to talk to
someone you can talk with your counselor
in a private online
environment at your own convenience from
wherever
you're comfortable better help
counselors have expertise in a broad
range of areas such as
depression like i talked about
relationships difficulty sleeping
trauma anger family conflicts
better help can give you access to help
that may not be available
in your area simply fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and get matched with your
counselor in under 48 hours
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with a therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages you
know i do
everything you share is confidential and
if for any reason you're unhappy
with your counselor you can request a
new one at any time no additional charge
join the one million plus
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
better help counselor in fact so many
people have been using better help they
currently are recruiting additional
counselors
in all 50 states better help is an
affordable option and our listeners get
off your first month with the discount
code
inside get started today at
betterhelp.com
inside that's dot com betterhelp.com
i-n-s-i-d-e talk to a therapist
online and get help inside of you is
brought to you by
magic spoon i love
me some magic spoon ryan
when i was a kid i would just eat you
know those cereals that you would just
chow down on
you know those cereals i don't know if
we're allowed to say those cereals well
why the hell can i no just those cereals
yeah but you know they were they had the
big
fun pictures on the front and they were
fruity
or they were chocolaty or they were
lucky whatever they were they were
delicious but now i'm an adult and
they're like you
shouldn't eat like that you're you know
the guy wilford brimley's like you're
gonna get diabetes
and you know all this crap and i'm like
finally there's a uh
there's a cool alternative they sent me
magic spoons sent me these boxes
look at this fun and you're like oh
these are fun
but check this out zero sugar
three net carbs 11 grabs of protein
cocoa flavored it's chocolatey
grain-free cereal yeah look at you ryan
what is that that's the uh frost
that's the blueberry i got the fruity
and the cocoa
i'm telling you i'm not gonna say what
it tastes like
i'm gonna say it's delicious it really
is delicious growing up cereal is one of
the best parts of being a kid but i had
to give it up
all right we all had to give it up did
we have to give it up we did because
you realize it's full of sugar and junk
that you probably shouldn't eat and you
grow up and then blah blah blah
everybody knows that you should eat
breakfast right breakfast is the most
important meal of the day
right yup why shouldn't you have a
little fun with breakfast why shouldn't
you have a little fun
in a healthier way magic spoon zero
sugar 11 grams of protein and only three
net grams of carbs in each serving
four flavors this is the variety pack i
got i really suggest you get the variety
pack i mean you got the cocoa the fruity
the frosted the blueberry keto friendly
gluten free
grain free soy free low carb and gmo
free tell me where to go ryan
go to magicspoon.com iou to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to get free shipping and magic
spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money
no questions asked come on that's
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou for free
shipping
we thank magic spoon for sponsoring our
podcast
and giving us a bunch of delicious free
cereal
inside of you is brought to you by quip
if you haven't heard of these guys
i don't know where you've been because
uh they have a great product and you've
heard people talk about the millions of
times ryan when's the last time you get
rewarded for brushing your grill
never never right that's true never
nobody rewards you but quip
rewards you equip has a new smart
electric toothbrush
and good habits can earn you great perks
like free products gift cards and more
so what's crazy is they have this app
and bluetooth right you connect it to
bluetooth everybody knows how to do that
it's very simple it's
even i can do this and it tracks how
well you're brushing how long you're
brushing these things which then can
give you rewards
you're getting rewarded essentially
getting money back if you think about it
ryan
the quip smart brush for adults and kids
connects to the quip
app with bluetooth like i said you track
how well you brush
you get tips and coaching to improve
your habits you earn points for daily
brushing
if you already have equip upgrade it
with a smart motor and keep the features
you know and love
sensitive sonic vibrations two minute
timer 30 second pulses for guided clean
i love it i love it i love it all beyond
the brush quip has everything you need
to build a complete routine
mint or watermelon toothpaste with
anti-cavity ingredients for strong and
healthy teeth
eco-friendly solar battery charger to
power your equip
with sunshine quip is doing it all
plus you can get brush heads toothpaste
floss refills delivered from five
dollars and shipping is free
how smart is that right incredibly join
over 5 million males who use quip
and save hundreds compared to the other
bluetooth brushes
when you get equipped smart brush for
just 45 dollars
do you know how much i've spent on these
really expensive like
300 toothbrushes thinking it's going to
be oh this is going to make the
difference
no i could you could you don't have to
spend hardly anything and then you get
rewarded
start getting rewards for brushing your
teeth today go to quip.com
y o u right now to get your first
refill free that's your first refill
free
at get quip dot com slash u y o
u spelled g e t q u i p dot com
slash y o u quip
better oral health made simple
and rewarding have you ever seen jared
cry
like for real yeah like really crying oh
yeah you've seen him emotional
oh yeah has he seen you emotional
uh yeah yeah i just i don't know i just
thought that you know how my mind goes
i'm like i wonder if they've ever seen
each other cry like i've never seen
welling cry
i mean i've seen welling a little
emotional but this was post smallville
and
you know it was kind of i didn't think
welling was emotional
i thought i was i i i thought he was
literally built in a lab of old actor
parts uh
well he'd like to hear that and he'd
probably laugh at that he would laugh
you know i've seen him like a little
emotional when it came to uh there was
some personal stuff years ago but
i'm not gonna talk about that but there
was yeah there was like a moment you
know i somehow
saw him like a little vulnerable and
like you know i mean he's he's like
maybe
he's like uh you know tough on the
outside with a tommy boy just saying
with the m
m's we say it's like you know they're
really hard on the outside but really
you know whatever you know it's like
shut up richard
uh but you know it's funny because and
bruce campbell was talking about
i love you you're talking bruce campbell
by the way fun fact for you yeah
they were they went to him and i i think
only him
to come back to uh uh play our father uh
because in the pilot episode jeffrey
dean morgan
who we all know and love uh played
our dad right but he was playing our dad
when my character was six years old
right because jeff's jeff's only like 10
11 years older than right
so he was playing uh the dad to
young uh dean and sam so when
flash forward when at the the into the
pilot
we go we go looking for dad because he's
gone missing but we haven't seen what
present day dad looks like
so they actually went out to bruce
campbell to play present day dad
wow whatever reason they they couldn't
uh and i think that was the only
that was the only person that that they
wanted could you imagine going around a
corner dad dad and he turns around and
goes look at he goes
groovy
uh so yeah so he was but uh ultimately
they couldn't they couldn't make it
happen
whether it was schedule or whatever and
so they kind of threw their hands in the
air and they're like well
maybe we can just gray jeff up and have
him come back
and play an older version of himself and
so ultimately that's what they did
thank goodness because there was he you
had the continuity and plus
jeff just you know he's so good knocked
it out of the park
um so yeah but yeah oh bruce almost made
it to the
supernatural that would have been nice
let me ask you something with five
months
with your wife and kids longer than you
ever had with them really
seriously uh not uninterrupted you know
not not consecutively in that that
uh that and you know that isolated is
that hard
were you like all of a sudden because
that's the first time you've dealt with
it or was it
was i mean look you could say of course
not i love daniel i love my kids
it's not hard it's easy no i think look
i don't i don't know anybody and if and
if they said that i wouldn't believe
them that that thing said ah this was
a walk in the park this was such a
lovely experience you know
it was i would say it was that there
were some beautiful memories made
but they're it's it was tough it was a
massive
um adjustment both you know both
emotionally physically and and mentally
and
all of the above and it was uh
but luckily she and i have you know
we've got a
solid partnership and friendship and
relationship
um that we just kind of you know
got into got into a groove um
you know i got home and immediately the
kids were not going to school so now we
were
we were uh teaching them taking turns
teaching them
that's what terrifies me yeah so i would
say there
there was there's some beautiful there
were some challenging aspects to it
but looking back on it i i it won't
it'll be looked back on fondly for sure
yeah i mean when you teach the kids uh
school how old do you have
twins so i've got uh my twins are three
and a half and then my
uh my oldest is uh just turned seven
um so she's going and she'll be going
into
second grade or would be going to second
grade so we're finishing up first grade
so
stuff that you know that we can handle
you know reading and writing
and math and that kind of stuff like
your basics all those things scare me
all of them well here's here's where i
feel you know i feel bad for the parents
that have like you know
ninth graders or you know eighth grade
eight ninth
ten like i don't remember that like
algebra and trig
and like all that stuff like that i
haven't done that stuff
since then no so i think they'd have a
better shot
if we both were studying at the same
time for this i i think they'd have a
better
shot of passing honestly right same
material you know
the social aspect of uh
you know the younger children i think is
really what they're missing out on the
most but as far as the educational
aspects of it the curriculum to get
that the the schools are sitting home
are pretty easy to follow
and and deliver from from our standpoint
anyway
um but yeah the older kids i i i would
i would hate to have to deal with that
for sure let all right well this isn't
the last thing there's a little
there's only 30 minutes for god's sakes
we're almost there we're almost there
you know i don't like to do long
interviews
obviously i love you i've known you for
a long time
you're a great guy but you're also on a
show and you're a character that people
just love they all around the world it's
just uh it's a
and that's a rare thing that's a rare
thing and i think i know
some people some actors we all do it
will think you know we got to prove that
we could do something else we've got to
do this we've got to do this i'm like
wait a minute wait a minute
you're one of the biggest shows ever
what do you have to prove what are you
jensen ackles so do you ever look like i
gotta prove myself
i gotta write i gotta do this or do you
do things really because you just
[ __ ] love those things right
yeah how many lotteries do you have to
win to be considered success
right are you are you pretty content or
are you do you want to do more things
because you just love acting you love
creating you love producing and you want
to keep doing that or is it more like a
balance like
i got to stay in the limelight got to
stay in this got to be present got to be
relevant do you feel any of that
pressure
uh sure sure absolutely i mean there's a
lot of people asking me you know what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
what's next what's you know what do you
want to do
um and i i yeah i i think i'd be
uh deaf and blind and insensitive if i
didn't
if that didn't at least affect me in
some way or if i wasn't like oh yeah
maybe i should
maybe i should come up with a game plan
but i've always been a
i've always been a you know let's just
see where the where the wind takes me
you know let's let's roll with the
punches and and
see what comes down that i mean i'm not
going to sit around and
you know wait like i will i will be
active and
pursuing things that interest me but
uh i don't uh i try not to allow myself
to feel the pressure
that makes you know because you can you
can tell especially
with actors when they're desperate oh
yeah i can do that
yeah i i i don't care if there's a
certain
yeah i think there's a certain odor that
comes with that
yeah and and it's if you can stay away
from that
you can be content and still stay
confident and still push
uh you know still push the the ball down
the road that i think
i think things happen for you um but
like you said
i'm uh i don't feel like i need to
reinvent myself
you know i've spent 15 years honing
uh a certain type of character and
and honing the skills that are needed to
do that and tell
tell story um so why not
why not parlay that into into the next
uh situation um you know somebody was
like what are you what are you going to
do are you going to
uh you know try to do romantic comedies
are you going to try to do something
completely out of the box
and sure that all sounds fun but i also
know that
um i enjoy playing
the character the type of character that
is that is dean winchester because
clearly because i've done it for 15
years and i'm not
i don't want to you know i don't want to
destroy that i wanted his legacy to be
great i want the show's legacy to be
great i've enjoyed playing that
character
so why wouldn't i want to play a similar
character on a different stage
right so uh
you know but at the same time it's like
i don't know maybe something comes along
and
uh you know i i i get a call
to go meet chuck lori and then all of a
sudden i'm on a half hour
you know that's i i'm kind of i don't
say oh this is my lane i'm gonna stay in
it
but i do also understand that the
you know the the audience uh
that has been built over the past 15
years is used to see me in a certain
light
and i'm happy to stay in that light as
long as as long as it stays
lit see that's you know it's awesome
because you're so you're
i could just tell you're so comfortable
with yourself and you're so honest i
mean obviously
you're you know i've since i met you how
old were we
i was like 25 26 you were like 22. or
yeah 23.
yeah it's just a good attitude to have
and i think it's something that you know
as i get older
i just think you know as long as look
again
caveat if i have a family
and i have to make money and i have to
pay
which i do i still have to pay bills i
don't have a family i still have to pay
for my mom [ __ ]
but um you know i don't care what i do i
will get i'll work at wendy's i'll
i don't give a [ __ ] i will work to make
money from my family
but i am very lucky and i'm not you know
i don't have i'm not
i have a nice house and i as long as i'm
comfortable
i'm good and i'm not gonna take jobs nor
i think with anybody
just just to work i want to work because
i really love something and if i'm able
to do that
then that's i'm very grateful that if i
can do those things so all i say to you
is like
you could do whatever you want and
there's no doubt that you could be on
a show tomorrow if you took meetings
with networks
i know he's on a hit show he's got a
huge following
it's a done deal so i would just say
man just enjoy it and get the right
thing don't jump on something else that
you might because you got lucky because
you love this series and it's a good
series
but you might not get that lucky again
we don't always get that lucky again
remember winning the lottery twice and
i'm not giving you advice i'm just
saying because you've had a more
successful career than i am
all i'm saying is like hey
if you don't need to go do something
don't do it because you're like uh
you know it could be no man because the
next thing
just love it just just love it and say
you know what i'm gonna have some fun
that's well and that's i think there's a
lot of pressure uh
you know on me maybe it's from me and
from you know the people in my camp and
stuff
uh of of what that transition piece is
gonna be coming out of supernatural
you know and uh and i do think that
that's that probably has a little bit
more
uh pressure on it than maybe what comes
next down the line
um so i do want to be thoughtful
about my next move uh
just from a strategic standpoint you
know
um because i want that to be able to set
me up for something
moving forward right whether it's a
movie or a
short order uh streaming network thing
or
or a guest arc on an existing program or
whatever it might be
but i think it should be something that
uh that
is um
that the it's it's not too drastic
it's not you know all of a sudden he's
a serial killer yeah well yeah or in
some like crazy period piece and
and you know is in drag mr winchester
yeah right yeah yeah whatever it might
be and and but by the way
that might be fun to do down the road
right um
but i think it's important to kind of
stay
stay in the ballpark of where i've been
really uh
happy and successful for the past uh
nearly two decades
uh and then transition you know uh in in
a good way
so that the the audience is like oh yeah
yeah yeah that makes sense
i like that i want to see him do that
you know who did that pretty well
was uh nathan fillion he sort of did
yeah yeah
i know i know philly pretty well and i
i've asked him i have asked him about
that
uh and you know he's he did navigate
that very very
well uh he's certainly someone to to
emulate
the only thing i would say is like i
know that a big part of this too is
agents can be very influential in terms
of like hey man this is the time to
strike this is what we need i know but
you got this producer because remember
they see paychecks they get a chunk
so just i i've done it i'm like oh okay
i should probably do that
why did i do that i didn't really want
to do that i guess i made him happy and
i made my
business manager happy so i asked
everybody's happy but now i have to go
to work and i'm not
i don't know if i really want to i'm not
i'm not that happy i'm not happy but
maybe you're just not all of a sudden i
just write down this new project that i
really want to do and i'm not available
yeah i just so you know i don't i'm not
i'm not saying anything i just
i don't know it is true you gotta you
gotta be smart you gotta navigate all
that you gotta understand that you know
at the end of the day you gotta do
something
that uh um you know that lights your
fire
you came out with an album i did as did
you
yes i did yeah i think that's the new
midlife crisis go-to uh project now
you know what though i will say this my
reason for doing it is i was terrified
i was terrified and with that terrifying
feeling
i just loved it so much that i was
scared but i was like
you know i kept thinking i don't i don't
have the chops i
i'm not a great singer i'm not it's
always just this this this but dude but
do you love it
so go do it who cares why do you care
that's that's [ __ ] you sound great
like i i i would thank you i've heard
you've seen before i've heard you play
before
listening to your album i was like so
glitch
well that's well that's how i feel about
you and i'm like we say midlife crisis
we go actor or
singing but you know what if you love it
and you know what you have
all i'm saying is i did it and i didn't
do it because it was like a it was just
one of those maybe it was midlife crisis
it was like one of those things like why
why haven't you done this oh you're a
little too old now just [ __ ] do it
do it for you and i did it and i was so
grateful aren't you grateful i mean
you've done
albums and things like that but this is
like never i've never like
i've never written and constructed one
from the from the you know
tip to stern yeah right this is the
first one because you've been on other
albums like i have like songs and things
like that and you're like
and you sound great i'm like he should
do an album so you did an album and
how hard was it i mean it was not that
not that hard at all it was
by that i mean yeah it took time it took
you know
you had to commit and stuff but it was
really fun
you have a natural voice though like i'm
i'm not i'm listen i'm saying
you can really sing when i heard you
singing in front of many people at live
shows and things i was like
i don't know if i could do that it
always scared me jensen just
has that i don't know you've always had
a great voice and
so i knew it would be easier for you to
me to get comfortable with something
i've never had a lesson i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing but
what's your favorite song on the album
oh gosh
well i got it right here i'm going to
play a little sounds of sunday if you
someday dude radio company
where did you come up with that was it
just a kind of a
it was uh it
there's a there's one of my favorite
coffee shops in austin texas
is called um radio coffee and
uh and so i for sure i'm sure that that
likes
uh subliminally influenced it but
also um steve carlson who i made the
album with
he and i were talking like you know what
kind of music we want to do what kind of
because he
we we're our influences is across the
board
you know uh he likes to say it's from
motown to metallica
and uh and so we're like well we just
like want
stuff that that is good music to keep
you company
you know like when you flip on the radio
it's just good company music
ooh radio company funny enough uh one of
my favorite songs is actually not even
one i
i sing it off my mind is just from a
production standpoint i think just a
really cool
tune that's one of one of steve's songs
but uh i also
the one i like to sing the most i think
would probably let me be
although
see i couldn't do this the voice range
here for you
come on i mean good lord son
a daughter mean how did you blow your
vocal cords out it was funny we actually
recorded vocals and the band
all of it ever at one time that's the
way to do it because it's the energy
when i have to sing
solo after the band's recorded and
they're all staring at me that's hard
that's very i found that the most
difficult as far as
from a process standpoint that was the
most difficult was singing in a vocal
booth with headphones on and a
microphone staring at you
and that's it i would get so frustrated
like when i go on a you know we do these
conventions these supernatural
conventions i'll go out and i'll play
with uh you know
the fan loud and swayed as uh rob
benedict's fan and they they come out
and they do a whole concert sunday night
or saturday night and and they'll have
some of the actors
that that you know want to come up and
do it's kind of like you know the last
waltz you know they'll come up and
they'll sing a tune or whatever
right it allowed me to come up and sing
a few times with them and it's a totally
different
like that's i mean there's so much
energy your voice is like you know the
adrenaline is pumping
and it's like your voice is doing things
that you probably wouldn't normally do
and that experience i'm like oh cool
i'll just take that right into a
recording studio
yeah yeah it was just amazing just to be
in the studio i'd never been
in and like jason mann's who we love i'm
sitting there playing the song i wrote
and he goes hey what's that rosie i go
ah just this little love song already
let's get in the studio let's plug him
in let's do that song
we did two takes and that was like i
think my favorite song and the album was
just impromptu
yeah we had a couple like that you know
that that are just kind of like
it's just easy yeah you're not trying
really easy
and uh um
come on
that got on the show actually they used
that on supernatural
come on do you sound like you're like
from the freaking like
van zandt from like leonard skinner and
[ __ ]
you know they always say actors actors
can't there's some actors that can
[ __ ] play music there's a lot of
actors all of a sudden they just do
stuff and you know that's like i don't
know
but hey they loved it i i also think
there's a stigma too that you know
actors shouldn't cross over to singing
yeah [ __ ] why and i don't know why that
is because
you look at you look at singers and they
cross over to acting all the time
yeah or or try to you know i mean
timberlake's done a great job uh you
know there's
there's there's people that have had
very lucrative careers in the music
industry
uh you know you look at uh what rihanna
did that ocean's eight with sandy
bullock and all that i mean
nobody bats an eye at that well how
about uh guys and
actors and films the crossover now you
could act in movies you could act in tv
you could do commercials you could be
the guy who won the oscar for the drum
thing jk simmons is doing those
uh commercials uh yeah doing farmers and
shirts and oscar no one gives a [ __ ]
just be good at what you do
or enjoy what you're doing no one cares
anymore yeah
i feel like they're that's the last kind
of stigma that's that's uh
that people are a little hung up on is
actors being able to do because they
think you know it's like a vanity
thing it's like oh i interested you know
it's like oh it's like back in the day
it was
you know every actor had to be able to
sing and dance that's right i don't plan
on you know starting dance lessons
anytime soon but
i don't know i bet you could dance you
know as funny as that you walked here
no joke you look this up after after we
get off but
i get a call from uh uh from our
showrunner andrew dad and he's like hey
axe uh can you dance
and they've thrown so i give you the
weird [ __ ] that they come up with in the
writer's room
usually falls in my lap uh
and they usually like to make dean dean
do it
so i'm like what uh what
what kind of dance they're like you know
like fred astaire
i'm like no andrew i i've never had a
lesson i don't i mean
like singing in the rain [ __ ] yeah i'm
like
i keep i probably keep beat you know
uh and he's like well you know would you
uh would you mind taking a couple of tap
lesson
tap dance lessons and and see if we
can't uh he's like i've got this whole
dream sequence and i want you to
to go have a dream sequence where you're
uh you know like a singing in the rain
type thing
and i'm like ah sure why not let's try
it
so i did like three hours of lessons
of tap dancing lessons and ended up
doing like this whole
just like a maybe a minute and a half
minute 45 second
routine uh tap dance routine on
on the on the show and how exciting are
you so glad you did it
it was i mean it was really i my thing
is i get really like competitive with
myself so
like i wasn't getting it at first i like
i think i i
the poor camera guys and stuff because
it was a huge you know camera suite that
was on a crane and
you know big jib arm and it was a big
you know and we did the whole
thing it wasn't like we cut it up into
segments we kind of did
we tried to do the entire thing in like
one swooping shot
and i think i must have done it like
like 18 different takes
i was like no i missed that one step
let's do it again i think camera guys
are probably
they're used to going no one more no one
more no come on let's go again
they just they might get annoyed but you
got to just whatever
if you have any sense i usually like
that like i i'm i'm you know i pride
myself on
knocking it out in one take for most
things uh
but this i was like i just you know it
was out of my comfort zone and i
i wasn't gonna i wasn't gonna settle and
so i just kept
i kept dancing kept dancing kept dancing
i mean i must have i used to burn
10 000 calories that afternoon and
that's when your makeup artist said
you're looking a little skinny jensen
i just tap danced yeah a [ __ ] dancing
woman
good lord they're hard on the outside
which one
i miss him god i miss him all the time
there's nobody funnier than chris farley
i talk about it all the time i jump into
it inadvertently
what's your favorite farley quote oh
would you call the u.s embassy i don't
speak
japanese i say it live good lord
i don't know what the one line i i would
i probably use the most
and this is something that gets thrown
back at me quite often from my wife as
well we use it on each other
is any time she or i is going like oh
wow look at this
desk this is fantastic i mean you could
i mean this
you put so much stuff in here yeah
anything you want to keep cold tommy
which i guess is a brian dennehy well no
but it's a tommy boyce scene you're the
only boy scene is like
yeah yeah anything you want to keep cold
tommy can i take my blindfold off i
never told you to
wear one i think my favorite one
is when he's talking to the girl from
married with children i forgot the
actress's name
uh christina christina applegate gosh i
should know that from the pm dawn song
remember
christina applegate you got it going on
why do i remember pm dawn but i don't
remember christina abigail i don't know
so there's a scene where he's uh missing
us
yeah christine applegate he got it going
now uh
he's with david spade and christina
applegate he says what do you want
knew it you're alive to christina
applegate because i want to live in a
van down by the river
and he goes you can see he's getting
pissed off he's like
well you have a lot of time limiting the
man down by the
river when you're living in a van
down by the river
the best the best is watching spade try
to hold it together
the whole tank just
shut your yapper
inside of you is brought to you by lucy
hi lucy
lucy nicotine is a company founded by
caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't suck i
just got my shipment i've been smoking a
little bit i hope
my mom's not listening to this or my
grandma but i hate that i'm doing that
and when westwood one called and said
hey lucy would like to be a sponsor
i said are you kidding me this is it was
a godsend for god's sakes i wanna
i wanna stop smoking it's embarrassing
to say because i'm not a heavy smoker
but the fact that you're smoking at this
day and age but you got to stop this
crap and the one way you do it is
lucy lucy's an alternative and it's uh
the gum tastes delicious
i mean you know i could chew this all
day
but you know you probably shouldn't chew
it all day should you research and
develop for three years to be made for
people
not patience i love that lucy has
created a nicotine gum with four
milligrams of nicotine that comes in
three flavors
wintergreen cinnamon pomegranate i got
the pomegranate
i like the pomegranate but i'm going to
try the cinnamon and the wintergreen
soon
lucy also has a lozenge with four
milligrams of nicotine and cherry ice
flavor each and every flavor
actually tastes great and that's true
it's convenient
it's discreet products can be enjoyed
anywhere on flights at work
on the go or even in the gym hey ryan
it's 2020.
get rid of your cigarettes unplug your
vape throw out your dip and get some
lucy nicotine gum or lozenges this is
the real deal a subscription to lucy
comes directly to your door
each month it's so simple that you don't
have to leave your house because lucy
has delivery
down listeners go to lucy.co
and use promo code inside to get 20 off
all products
including gum or lozenges that's lucy.co
and use promo code inside at checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code
inside of you is brought to you by
hydrant uh you know what this is this
was a blessing in disguise ryan because
i'm constantly dehydrated i never drink
enough water i get fatigued i wonder why
and then i start using this electrolyte
powder the electrolyte powder that
hydrant
makes which we're going to talk about
and
i do it a couple times a day and i feel
like i have more energy and it's it's
it's amazing how when you hydrate
you always think there's something wrong
with you i gotta take these pills i
gotta
i gotta take uh whatever i gotta drink a
soda
and then you just take some electrolytes
some powder and water and mix it in an
eight ounce glass or whatever and all of
a sudden i'm like
i feel pretty good hydrants
they're bad ass yeah summer's here it's
crazy hot outside we all know that we
should drink
more water but by the time we feel
thirsty guess what you're already
dehydrated that's right you can't focus
you feel tired
drinking enough water is critical for
healthy lifestyles
it increases your brain power boosts
your productivity it prevents
headaches increases your focus it
improves your skin
and mood look at my skin ryan glowing
yeah it helps your digestion gives you
energy it helps
prevent bad breath and it can even help
you lose weight but how much
should we drink each day 10 cups a
gallon it's confusing
the good news is that it doesn't have to
be so complicated and that's why i start
my day with hydrant hydrant has created
a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into water to more efficiently and
effectively hydrate your body
hydrates you quickly and keeps you going
longer
if you're looking for that extra boost
of energy there's also a hydrant plus
caffeine which contains 100 milligrams
of caffeine from green tea and hydrant
is backed by research the formula was
developed by an oxford scientist
it's also loved by pro athletes top
performers celebrities and thousands
of five star reviews and it's made with
real fruit juice powder
is delicious and refreshing and comes in
a variety of flavors including
new summer friendly iced tea lemonade
and fruit punch
yummy plus it's backed by a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee you don't
love it you send it back
full refund we've got a special deal for
our listeners to save 25
off your first order all you do is go to
drink
hydrant dot com slash inside
or enter our promo code inside at
checkout that's
a n d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n-t dot com
slash i
n s i d e and enter promo code inside
for
25 off your first order drink hydrant
dot com
slash inside enter the promo code inside
to save 25 percent
and we thank hydrant for sponsoring
our podcast really quick these are rapid
answers you don't have to talk it's [ __ ]
talking with jensen actors these are my
patrons
i have a patreon account they they love
the podcast they support it
they're amazing they get to ask
questions ask questions nico
is there a movie that you're excited to
watch with your kids someday but can't
watch it just yet because they're just
aren't old enough
uh yeah i i never read nor watched
any of the harry potters ever and i got
so late in the game
that i was like you know what i'm just
gonna wait until the kids are old enough
to do that
and i tried to watch the first one uh
this past year with my oldest who was
six at the time
and it was too soon so
i literally left the room for five
minutes to go to the bathroom and that
was when voldemort came out
and then next thing i know is she's just
like standing in the bathroom with me
i'm like
what what are you doing she's like
there's a really scary man on the tv
right now
i'm like okay and i came out and i'm
like good lord you're right
that has no face turned it off so i'm
excited to start that
whatever that whatever that time is but
i i
you know what her favorite two movies
are right now princess pride
of course and the original charlie and
the chocolate factory oh wow
and that's creepy yeah i know i know but
man g wilder's
so good there's nobody better in that
movie i mean that movie
his performance what does he say i
always forget it
at the very end you messed with my fizzy
lifty drinks which now need to be
cleaned and sterilized
good day sir you get nothing and he says
you're a mean man wonka and then charlie
comes over
and charlie puts down the everlasting
gobstopper and what does he say
and so shines a good deed in a weary
world
that's just like it's it's on his back
yeah
yeah all right little lisa what what's
your favorite scene you filmed on
smallville probably when you and i were
naked tied up in some dungeon or
something
probably yeah oh god i remember that
that was terrible
uh favorite scene i tell you my least
favorite scenes was
anything having to do with football and
i love football but put not but
i mean the fact that i was the junior
coach
it was it was so bizarre yeah it was a
little bizarre
it was bizarre uh fair scene i you know
i i i'm kissing kristen come on
yeah yeah let's just go with casey i
mean that's the obvious choice obvious
choice danielle you won't get mad he
said this is years ago he was a child
a child daniel she won't listen to this
anyway she doesn't listen to you does
she
i'll tell her we're talking about her
maisha with supernatural being over have
any interesting projects been brought to
you can you hint on any is there
anything that
maybe you're kind of you can't really
talk about that something that's here
that's brewing
yes okay good answer good answer
good answer why say something if it does
then it doesn't happen like whatever
happened to that 10 years from now like
i
don't know that's one thing i've done
that early on is don't talk about
auditions
ever oh no no no my mom still asked me
if i got private ryan
all right mom it's on it's a classic now
have you told her yes
yes mom i'm the sniper there i am right
there right there can't see me i died
i'm one of those bodies on the beach
samantha k what was your favorite part
about starting your own family brewery
how is that doing with current world
events good question
uh free beer and uh a continuous supply
up here
uh i can go to the brewery anytime i
want and get beer
now can you send that beer or you you
can't send that
no because we it's there's a lot a lot
of alcohol board
uh log we can only if we distribute
outside a certain
radius then we have to like sign with a
distributed distribution company and
that's a
you know that's like next level stuff so
you don't make cans you just
glasses of beer mugs of beer we make
cans we make cans we we sell it to
local grocery stores and liquor stores
and markets and stuff so you can buy
uh we have three flagship flavors that
you can buy at uh
like 52 different locations in
in central texas what if you just sent
me as a gift
and then i then mode you and then i
could just have like a classic edition
of a jensen apple's beer
beer can yeah i'd have to i mean look
off the record you could probably just
anybody could probably grab a six-pack
off the shelf and then wrap it up and
fedex it to you that's that's probably
okay all right you guys know who you are
you live in texas let's get right
let's get over there somebody send mike
some uh some beer yeah
uh nancy d what's the one roll you drop
everything to play or the one person you
would drop
everything to work with good question
i would say there's there's some iconic
uh
characters that have really shaped kind
of who
uh the style that i enjoy
playing and the characters and stuff you
know you think of
indiana jones and you think of uh uh
john mclean and you think of uh
but a role like that or working with
spielberg zemeckis you drop everything
to work with those guys right oh gosh
yeah
yeah and even like you know chris nolan
and like some of these really innovative
like
creative directors now um
yeah that would be that would be a game
changer chris chris
f what props from the show do you keep
or do you want to keep when the show
ends come on you gotta have something
yeah i'm i'm not
keep i'm not keeping anything oh what's
one that you would like
warner brothers i'm not keeping anything
i promise uh
the car but one that i might like might
be some of the iconic ones like
uh an angel blade or
um you know maybe some of the uh
the non the non-lethal weapons that we
uh we used but
uh i will say that the the big one
is one that i can share that i i am
taking home with me and that was
that was sanctioned by warner brothers i
i'm getting the car
what have you not told anybody about
that i may have mentioned it but
i i that's the big news that's big news
that's incredible are you gonna are you
gonna drive it are you gonna keep it in
your garage and just keep it there
you know for all times sake my my plan
as of now
is with the show when we wrap up the
show here and
here in a few weeks they're gonna hand
me the keys and i'm gonna put that
sucker on a car carrier
ship her home to texas uh and i've gotta
i got a couple of folks that uh
um that i'm talking to uh is that your
contract did you say i want that mic it
was what season did you do it uh i've
been talking about that for two years
now
and it finally they finally added that
to my contract this last season
is there a double there is and they i
think they offered it to jared i don't
know if he's going to take it because
it's you know it's kind of beat up and
it's like
i'll take it i'll take this exactly i
mean he might say i don't know he's
going to do with it but
the hero the hero car the one that we're
the one that we always drive
oh dude that's so cool man that was
coming home with me
and it's i'm gonna i'm gonna clean her
up but not change
not change anything like but i'm gonna i
might just you know
i'm gonna need to add an air
conditioning unit because we live in
texas
uh i'm probably i'm probably gonna
probably get some new speakers in a a
radio system in there that actually
works i'm blown away i'm blown away by
this
but everything else i'm just i'm going
to leave the creek in the doors the
splits and the seats
you know it's all going to be the same
can i ask for one thing can i ask for
one thing if it's still around
what i think you'll you'll laugh at this
and you'll be like you know what
i bet they still have them i want you to
sign it with a silver sharpie for me and
i'm going to keep them right there on my
table
your tap shoes from
your tap shoes for the singing and the
rain [ __ ] i want the black tap shoes
because you had to wear tap shoes
i want them is that possible i had to
yeah i could see where those are
yeah that would be huge there's a lot of
wardrobe stuff that i
you know they'll have a huge wardrobe
sale uh
at some point i don't know when but
there's a lot of stuff that was
that was built for me you know there was
there was like specific
uh i there we did a western episode
where we get sent back to like the 1800s
we have to find samuel colt because he's
got a he's got a gun that
bullets that we've got to get so we get
sent back in time and
you know of course my character goes
full uh
you know dodge city uh wyatt herb style
and they give me they they hand make me
just duster and these you know
full on like periods so those will
probably be for sale
yeah well but they you know it's it's
all
molded to me so
[Music]
that one might disappear may it
disappear i still want this tap shoot
last two questions quickly leanne p what
lessons has this quarantine taught you
and jerry w
who inspires you and why uh
what lessons has the quarantine taught
me uh that patience
is a tremendous virtue uh
and that
that depression is avoidable if you work
at it
are you saying okay that's good now let
me ask you about that
so have you found yourself a little
depressed a little anxious and what have
you done to sort of
alleviate that sure so i mean there's
you know there were
days where you just kind of like
and this is when i was back home uh not
here this is kind of a different
situation because
i'm in a 14-day quarantine with a huge
light at the end of the tunnel
that i know in in now uh
now 10 days from now work so that
that's a motivating factor not to get
you know bored or or
disheartened but you know two months ago
sitting at home
you know with the kids and hearing the
you know all the bad news on the news
and the
record setting uh spreading viruses
and it's you know it's like a freaking
zombie apocalypse on the horizon
um there were days and just like i
wander around i'm like
what am i supposed to be doing right now
like i have no purpose
and then that's when you take inventory
you're like no no no there's three
little kids over there that
that that give you a lot of purpose pal
so buck up and find something to do go
teach that kid you know
some math or go teach that kid go throw
that kid
onto the bed and and and play with them
and just make memories
um you know go make dinner for the kids
set them up in the movie room and then
have a nice date with your wife in the
kitchen
it's amazing though when you get caught
up and it's it's just not it's not that
you're not grateful it's not that you're
not
it's that you get overwhelmed and you
don't know why
and you should have this anxious feeling
and you feel like the sense of dread
and you forget all the things around you
that you could still do or still
uh you know and if you just get caught
too much i've done it man i
you know i you sit back there and i'm
alone here but uh
you know i go you know what my
grandmother needs me i'm going to call
my grandmother and i'm going to talk to
her for an hour on facetime i'm going to
start to do things and the busier you
get the weight you keep yourself busy it
just it helps but look we're all human
it's like on this show i talk about
anxiety i'm like you know stephen amell
came on here he had an anxiety attack
and then he came back and talked about
it it's like that's what we need more in
the world to let everybody know that
[ __ ] man
just because uh you know your favorite
character on supernatural dean here is a
successful hollywood star it has money
and a great family and all these things
and doesn't mean he doesn't feel
doesn't mean he doesn't get anxious and
and lonely and depressed and like what's
going on and talk you know so
i think it's important it's cool you
know there's there's a a
there's a very powerful scene in in a
very powerful movie
uh that i i thought about a lot over
quarantine
um remember the movie the hurt locker
charlie writer yeah
so i mean you have this soldier who who
comes back from
you know in between deployments and he's
there's this scene where he's walking
down
uh the grocery aisle and it's the cereal
aisle
and he just turns and looks at this just
wall of cereal
and he just stay he just stares at it
because he's just come from
basically fearing for his life around
every corner
disarming bombs being shot at uh
you know eating and drinking uh you know
slop and you know just
just in the [ __ ] uh over in iraq
and then he comes home stateside and
it's just like
you've got 47 different types of cereal
at your disposal
anything you want and it's just this
wall of of
uh what's the word i'm looking for
options or uh yeah of
a possibility yeah opulence you know
it's like all this
and i just that was powerful for me
because it was like um
it's almost like he didn't feel and i
this is
the movie resonates i think because he
feels like he's got
purpose over there but when he comes
home
it's like and i think a lot of problem
veterans feel that
and and i think a lot of people are
starting to feel that in quarantine it's
like when you're working when you have
when you have worth when you have
purpose when you have motivation to get
up and you do something
i haven't set my alarm clock in four
months
you know my alarm clock used to be set
every day to get up because i had people
waiting for me on set i had to get i
learned my lines
i had to read the next script i had to
figure out what i was doing i had to go
to stunt rehearsal
i had to go get uh you know a prosthetic
fitting i had
you know there's you're doing things
you're moving
you're motivated you're working you have
purpose and when you strip all that away
and all of a sudden it's like
what the what am i supposed to be doing
right now
that's that's that's a hard it's a hard
ocean to navigate
yeah um but i think that's when you lean
into
you know you find purpose and you look
around you and you take inventory and
you
you're like you know what i'm gonna call
my grandmother yeah you know what i'm
gonna go
i'm gonna take my kids outside and shoot
some basketball with them i'm gonna
i'm gonna call a friend i'm gonna i'm
gonna find some reason
to get motivated to to keep moving to
the next hour
so i you know we deal a lot with
uh um you know there's a lot in the
fandom that are
are beautifully vocal about their
struggles with
uh mental instability or or depression
or whatever it might be
and i've met a lot of these people that
that fight it on a daily basis and i i
don't envy that but i'm encouraged and
uh inspired by how they continually
continually do that on a daily basis
and so if i've felt like i've tasted
just a fraction of that throughout the
quarantine
uh i would say that what i've learned
from that is that
you've got to find a way to stay
motivated and find purpose
in every day and every moment and that
kind of gets you to the next moment
yeah and i also say that you know just
thank you for coming on today and you
being vulnerable and just talking about
real stuff like always
and just being real someone out there is
listening
and saying hey you know i i relate or i
get it or that's nice to hear and and
see what you're doing and what helps you
and you know it sounds like you we all
need routine whether you're doing a tv
show or whether you're watching kids or
you know if you're watching kids which
is probably the hardest job in the world
at home
stay-home mom or dad or you know it's
like hey wake up do something for
yourself real quick before the kids wake
up
exercise find the time for you or you're
going to implode it has got to be that
time for you
or it doesn't matter whether you have
kids or a wife or you got to get right
i would assume i'm i'm single but that's
oh and that's that was one thing that
daniel and i do is we we
you know it's not even talked about
anymore
i know when she needs to go and you know
go go out in the garage and work out or
you know i need to get on the phone and
talk to an adult
and we just like hand it's just a
handoff right it's like an unspoken
handoff like
i got i got the kids you go do what you
need to do right yeah
well dude i love it man i love it uh i
love talking to you i hope you'll come
on at least once a year
you know just gotta catch up you're just
a great guy you're i've known you for a
long time
yeah it's a lot of fun do you want to
say anything uh as in closing just to
just i mean i'm sure you've said it but
just to all the fans out there to
everybody who's
who's watched you for all these years
and uh anything at all i'm sure you've
already said this but
i mean look the fact that this show has
stayed on as long as it has is because
people uh have not just found us
but have stuck with us and uh
you know that that is that is all the
encouragement that i need to keep
working as hard as i possibly can
to provide the product the entertainment
that that i can for people
uh like all of you and it's um it is a
gift that you have given me
and it is a gift that i intend to
cherish and to utilize properly
uh i had a really great zoom call with
cory booker senator cory booker
yesterday
and uh uh he's uh
apparently a such a supernatural he's
watched the entire series twice
and he did he the second time he watched
it was during his presidential uh
campaign and uh but you know he said
some he gave me some really great piece
of advice he's like look when i
you know when i want to turn my brain
off i get to turn you guys
on and just escape into into the world
of supernatural
he's like that was a gift for me and so
the fact that you know that he even says
that is a gift right back so
that evan flows is alive and well and i
thank the audience
that is that has been giving me that for
15 years now and i
i hope to uh i hope to trans uh
translate that right into the next
project
whatever that may be by the way i think
that that's beautiful and i think that
you know all i can think of is like
some of your fans who don't really know
me and don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna
be like
he tried to get his tap shoes he tried
to get another car
he tried to get [ __ ] his beer i mean
what the [ __ ] is he just trying to get
free [ __ ] come on
leave me alone i know what you're
thinking i like toys look at my damn
place i'm gonna get through [ __ ]
yeah exactly dude i love you this has
been awesome and uh i wish you
all the best in the world uh all the
best of the family and
and the show and uh everybody's rooting
for you and
continued success man in health man uh
stay in touch and uh maybe let's talk
after the shows uh all wrapped up and we
can uh talk about the experience that'll
be fun i'd love that and i got something
to send you to all right brother man all
right buddy
ryan isn't how awesome is that that the
guy in his contract
got to keep the car from supernatural
that's pretty swell
wait til you hear next week when you
hear jared padalucki that episode
he gives us some knowledge he really
opened up there's some insight to that
story
there is and there's also some insight
to other stories things that
he was just open he was like i never
i've talked about this
and then he talks about it and i thought
he was gonna call me go hey man cut that
and he didn't and i respect that i like
that he's just to get the balls
uh thanks again for all the uh the love
and support uh
rosenbaum and dan so we're gonna be
doing another stage it we do them one
one a month on a saturday at two shows
a two p.m and a 6 p.m pacific time and
people are uh really gathering and
enjoying themselves we do zooms
for tippers and things like that so
we're gonna have another one soon so
we'll remind you that and now shout out
to my patrons and uh we're gonna go in
order of who joined first
bryce gave me that list oh nancy d mary
b
leah s trisha f sarah v little lisa
yukiko
jill e lauren g nico p barry i
angelina g robin s jerry w emily k
bob b robert b jason w stephen j
kristen krug no kristin k amelia oh
allison l tom and jess j lucas m
raj just have to say something when you
say raj you just see that name you have
to say something emily asked cjp
samantha m humza b jennifer n stacy b
carly t jennifer s genelbe we said
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
tabitha 2 7 3
kimberly e crystal h mike e marissa
ramirez beth b chris f chad w
leanne p jackie p rodrigo
s rachel
rachel what is this this is a new name
spell it out r a c e h l c
r a c e h l is it like a
is it it's got to be rachel or is it
raquel i don't know
raquel c rey a maya p megan d
jennifer c maddie ass tiffany i kendrick
f
ashley e margie m thomas t matt w
belinda n benjamin r lisa j kevin v
robert s joy w james r chris h
snow r noah k sean v
ass bomb h
i'm trying buddy a s b j o with a s
a line through it m asphone
h if i messed it up please phonetically
spell it out for me and i will
nail it next time why is this episode
two hours long
oh you know we couldn't read some names
at the end yeah so
yeah guys thanks so much for joining us
and i hope you enjoyed the episode keep
listening every week subscribe
uh i hope you're enjoying it and i'll
keep working on getting great guests
and having some great conversations so
we all learn a little something and
become
better human beings if possible uh thank
you for allowing me to be inside of
each and every one of you ryan thanks
for letting me open up about my skin
cancer to you
yeah uh i'm glad you're okay yeah knock
on wood man everything's gonna be fine
it's just uh
sometimes you get a call and you're like
all right gotta deal with that and
should be fine
most of the time it's probably gonna
work out right yeah yeah so you can't
worry about that stuff
yeah you go golfing and you continue on
your life
life is short we hear it every day and
we never listen until
it's over so don't let it over don't let
it over yep
i'm gonna get off the phone now thanks
[Music]
guys